[Arabic recitation]
نو خالد
‏wasn't here yesterday
call
s out bloodhounds
may traveling something for eat
sometimes he goes the phoenix for
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صلي صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين
اما بعد
ك ان
الوجيز في فقه السنه والكتاب العزيز
الجمعه
الصالحين
جمعه الصالحين
ان شاء الله
الجمعه صلاه الجمعه
كتاب
الوجيس يقول المؤلف شهود الجمعه
فرض عين على كل مسلم الا خمسه
عبد مملوك او امراه امراه او صبي او مريض
او مسافر قال الله تعالى يا ايها الذين
امنوا اذا نودي للصلاه من يوم الجمعه
فاسعوا الى ذكر الله وذروا البيع
ذلكم خير لكم ان كنتم تعلمون
وعن طارق بن شهاب عن النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم قال الجمعه حق واجب على كل مسلم في
جماعه الا اربعه
عبد مملوك او امراه او صبي او مريض وعن
ابن عمر عن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
ليس على المسافر جمعه
صلاه الجمعه
صلاه الجمعه رياض الصالحين
جمعه رياض الصالحين
جمعه
صلاه صلاه
الجمعه
[Silence]
‏virtueur
of
الجمعه
صلاه الجمعه
books are up
to the books of حديث
prophet صلى الله عليه وسلم
book
[Silence]
‏So the begin this chapter
he says that
attending
me the of
isat
عين
because
the oppos
المسلم العاقل البالغ
‏here
said
الله يا ايها الذين امنوا
اذا نودي للصلاه من يوم الجمعه فاسعوا الى
ذكر الله فعمم سبحانه
النداء الى جميع المسلمين الى جميع
المؤمنين ثم استثنى من ذلك النداء
من استثناهم سبحانه وتعالى
ieved
الله
[Silence]
يقول عبد مملوك
الجمعه
او امراه
او صبي
الصبي
هو ما دون
البلوغ المقصود بالصبي هنا ما دون البلوغ
او مريض
‏are tyes people
number
a female
someone who
number ‏someone who is traveling.
‏exception
when we take these kinds of things when
we hear these kind of things when we
learn these kind of things we are trying
to learn a method of approaching life
and that is to say if a person
to say I am not going to attend today
the question need to be which tye of
these am I
[Silence]
লা
طارق بن شهاب رضي الله عنه طارق بن شهاب
اختلف في صحبته
والراجح ان له سماع
ان له سماعا
رضي الله عنه
طارق بن شهاب
صلى الله عليه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
كان مخضما
المخضم من امن في عهد الرسول صلى الله
عليه وسلم الا انه لم يجتمع به مؤمنا به
اي مخضم
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم
تابعين
واحد بعض العلماء ماء المخضرم فقالوا من
شهد الجاهليه
والاسلام الا انه لم يدرك النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم او لم يل
عن طارق بن شهاب
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلى
عليه وسلم
completely
and complete all the way to the propet
in which propet himself صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الجمعه
جمعه
جماعه
يعني عبد مملوك عبد مملوك
هذه
هذه صفه بعد صفه انه هو عبد فلو قال
العبد
او المملوك لكفى لكن عبد مملوك
ايفن
عمر
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ليس على المسافر جمعه
جمعه
ان شاء الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يفقهنا في ديننا وان يعلمنا منه ما
جهلنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا والله اعلم
وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
دكتور ‏How are you?